[MUSIC PLAYING]
My name is Andreas Preuer
and I'm a partner development
manager at Google Play.
Today I will talk about
optimizing your game
with conversion funnel and
store listing experiments.
This is Tapventures a
game by Underwater Apps.
You've seen this game before.
It's a studio based in Armenia.
Underwater Apps came across
a few common challenges
such as how to increase
revenue per user,
how to get a better
understanding of your user's
price source and how to
grow the game's user base.
We've worked with
Underwater Apps
to overcome and address
some of these challenges.
Let's start with
challenge number one,
and I'll talk a little bit
about the player stats API.
So the challenge was, how to
increase revenue per user.
The player stats API which
is part of Google Play game
services helps you to predict
user's spend and churn.
Here are three simple ways
how do use spend and churn
prediction for
better experiences.
You can invest in users who are
predicted to become spenders,
you can make the game easier
for gamers predicted to churn,
or you can just show ads
to users who are predicted
not to spend otherwise.
Underwater Apps
made a simple change
and implemented the player stats
API to predict spend behavior
of their newly acquired users.
They didn't show ads to users
who were probable to spend.
This simply change
increased IAP count by 15%.
Now to challenge number two, how
to get a better understanding
of users by source.
Let's talk about Google
Play's conversion funnel.
The conversion funnel
simply shows you
visitors, installers, and
buyers by acquisition channel.
If you would like to
take action to increase
the number of installers you can
launch a universal app campaign
directly from Google
Play's Developer Console.
Ads will be shown on
Google's search network,
including Google Play, YouTube,
and Google's Display Network.
Launching soon, you will find
a country breakdown of Google
Play's conversion funnel.
You can drill into performance
in your key markets
and learn about
underperforming markets too.
If you learn that the
store listing visitors
to installer conversion
rate in a specific market
is below your expectation you
can launch a store listing
experiment to
improve performance.
Now to challenge
number three, how
to grow the game's user base.
Store listing
experiments allow you
to find the most
effective graphics
and text for your game.
Absolutely no coding is required
and it takes only a few clicks
to launch store listing
experiments in the Play
developer console.
You can test icons, images,
videos, and text descriptions.
Here are three recommendations--
use global tests for icons
and graphics.
Use local tests for
localized text and graphics.
And coming soon you can run
multiple localized description
tests at the same time.
Don't forget, your
Play Store listing
matters for all traffic sources.
Here you can see an example
from Underwater Apps
and their store conversion
rate increase by 29%,
just by updating
the icon design.
Check out our new features
and get in touch via the link
that you can see on the slide.
[MUSIC PLAYING]